Hi good morning President Lula very
welcome to the house of European Democracy
to the European Parliament thank you very much
for accepting the invitation of Global
Progresso and form 121 the GPS
and as the name Progresso Progressista says
I would like to ask what it is
for you  a Progressive agenda What should
a Progressive agenda have
to enrich the debates
that we are having this week
Look, I believe that a
Progressive agenda today in any part of the
world has to have three themes that are
inseparable first, inequality  it
is not possible that the progressive sectors
of society are not bothered by the
inequality that takes over the world In other
words, although the world produces food
necessary for humanity, the truth is
that we have 800 million
human beings who go to sleep every night without
having the  that and
another important thing is the
climate issue, that is, we need to take into
account that treating the climate issue seriously
today is  take care of the planet taking care of
our water, our forest, our
fauna is an obligation of survival, it is
not necessary for one country to put pressure on
the other, it is the obligation of every human being
kiss the day it is born it's until the day
I go to take care of your planet take care of the
water  who drinks taking care of the air they breathe
was taking care of the quality of
people's lives this is a second
important thing and the third important thing
is the generation of jobs for
humanity that is in this digital madness you
know that the 21st century we are
providing is allowed  let us
discuss how we are going to generate employment
to serve the millions and millions and
millions of young people who
have to go to the radio to work every day and who do not have a
job start to lose hope and
become desperate I think these are
three issues that we have to  solve
inequality rhymes and jobs to make
humanity return to live in a
peaceful and civilized way what is the role that
sells Brazil to have in this debt  even Brazil
plays an important role because Brazil
has 213 million inhabitants Brazil
is a country with an immense territory of eight
and a half million square kilometers Brazil
has a dry border with almost all
the countries of South America - with
Ecuador and  cochile that are almost 16 thousand
km long Brazil has 8,500 km of
maritime border Brazil has a lot of
mineral wealth in the subsoil in the soil and
Brazil has the largest tropical forest reserve
on planet Earth and Brazil it
gains a strategic importance on
planet Earth  and Brazil does not need
to discuss with other countries
who owns the Amazon Amazonia in
Brazil, but for Brazil to share with the
world the scientific exploration of the
potential of Brazilian biodiversity,
if it is true that subtropical forests
represent a balance on planet
earth, we do not have to  share
this country of ours with the world so
that the world can research and help
us develop the best development policy
development to generate the possibility
of survival for the people who live there
without us wanting to transform
Amazonas is a sanctuary of humanity it is
necessary to explore with intelligence Because
today the word economic growth and the
word economic are closely
linked to the word environment, so it is
necessary to take care of the  environment so
that we can have another model of
development and in this aspect Brazil
can contribute a lot to humanity
in which we try to say because
effectively in Europe
the debate on environment and employment often raises
economic growth and respect for the
environment  It is interesting to hear In your
words that you consider that they are not
incompatible,
on the contrary, that is, today, the eye where
you cannot think about
economic growth knows without thinking about
the environmental issue, what is needed is that we
think about the
sustainable economic growth in which we  can generate
employment can generate wealth and at the
same time  checking the environment we
live in the maintenance of ecosystems the
exploitation of biodiversity and it has to
be considered an economic factor we
don't need to destroy it is building
something else false That is, today I think
that always Progressive
to be environmentalist Always Progressive
is to be humanist, that is to be Progressive
is to speak a little with heart and a little
coal without Progressive is to be solidary
and fraternal to speak more about love, less
hate and more of a country with the words that
lead me to a topic that will now
be discussed next, which is the future of
Democracy because in order to have peace in order to
have economic growth we tend to
think that the best system that I can
provide will be the democratic system What
is your opinion on the state of
democracy in Latin America in your
own country but also looking at us
in Europe and abroad  the rest of the world what is
the police impression i can look at
my political life to talk about
democracy
so don't be  if it weren't for the
democratic system I would never want to learn from the
Republic of Brazil
if it weren't for democracy an
Indian like Evo Morales
would never reach the presidency of Bolivia What
is important is that you have to
establish the democratic political model
in which all people have
equality  and opportunity to
organize and be competent and at the same
time you have to have a
democratic economy in which everyone has the
conditions to have access to the calories and
proteins necessary for
human
survival.  for those who have money and for
those who don't, it must be
democratic the media
must be in all people it must have the
right to be heard by the
media does not own the newspaper The
owner of the television that is a  sensor it is
necessary that society has a
participation you know in this democratization
of the media
so democracy is an
Extra thing  ordinary insofar as it
allows me to say what I want
I do what I want what we don't
need to understand and I think the
progressive sectors can't open
damn request democracy doesn't mean
you say you want a job it means
you can work
democracy doesn't mean you say you
're hungry I scream that you're hungry it
means you eat democracy doesn't
mean you have the right to
have a good school it means you
have to be in school because of
digital democracy possibility that
we have to guarantee  that all
destruction be treated equally
and I have the same in the opportunity only the
word opportunities that has that to
differentiate and not the economic question It is
true but there are many risks and There are many
threats to this democracy today
for example social networks when they are
manipulated by some of the most
extreme forms of political opinions
can run the risk of is this
very  democracy prevent
people's access to this better world
Rico
the election of trump that in the United
States was a
risk or that is, everyone knows that the election
of trump was due to the construction of a
process of lies transmitted by
social networks that we do not  you can
call it a social network it's better to
call it a digital network than social
serving You know there's a lot there's a lot there's a
lot that is not social on
social networks in Brazil we have a
president who tells five lies a
day through social networks But
that's not  denies democracy, this only feeds us with
the need to live more
democratically because I'm not going to mention
that regulating social networks is
going to have to regulate the internet,
we're going to have to set a parameter, one
thing is for you to use the means of
communication for you to inform you
educating something else is to do evil
something else to tell a lie
something else is for the harm to society
no you won't use it  Using the means of
communication like the internet that
makes it possible for everyone to have access to
information like we've never had in our lives,
that is, we cannot allow
a revolution like
this
to be used.
algorithm I want to remain a
human being I don't want to be guided I
want to have feelings I want to define
what I do I want to define
what I buy I want to ask you to come back and
that we don't need to regulate so
that some smart and evil don't have
to  become the owner of humanity through the
manipulation of algorithms then the
self-regulation of economic factors And
especially in the digital world it's a
Chimera it's a dream for a closet to use one it's
a song that we have to make today
for example you have the people know that
what  they are the owners of the applications
all over the world they don't pay or matter
almost everyone in tax havens
earns a fortune and doesn't even pay
tax or even one this  of not paid in
Brazil not paid in Spain not paid in
Italy not paid in South Africa, that is,
it is not possible for these people to have
responsibility and for these people to have
responsibility to not allow
evil to be transmitted to each one of the
people I will  having the internet you see
people directing the other to kill themselves
you find them teaching you to do a lot of
evil that this has to be prohibited and
the app owners have to take
care of it so I think the
left doesn't have to be afraid of debating the
system  no matter how difficult they may be,
the solution is the debate AND the solution is
the democratic way out
we are with that is the same line, in fact, the
debate that we have been doing so far so
indicate that to end this conversation of ours I
would like to ask why the
GPS 21 motto this year  is if i can dream
we can do it in your case you are a
humanist Total What is your dream not
the generic dreams but concretely
for the next 10 15 years that you dream
what dreams do you have for you and your country
for the world
I always say that
all of us human beings have to dream a
lot with this big look because if
we
dream small when we wake up
we will be disappointed I'm
dreaming big that's it  a dream of a
more fraternal world
I dream of a more solidary world
I dream of the world where
Oi amore no hate where peace prevails and
in war I dream of a world
where people can eat 3 times a day
that the person can  having access to employment
to education having access to cultural activities In
other words, I dream of a
world where everyone can live with
dignity
and I dream of the world Lula
was also the common thing I think I have already fulfilled a
lot of my dreams I leave the  where I
left in the state a lot of people of Brazil and
getting to the presidency of the republic of my
country was already carrying out the realization of
a perspective that I had never
failed So I went now is to recover
democracy in my country I leave q  that
Brazil becomes democratic again Brazil
becomes a country knows that it is an
example to the world example in
the climate issue example in the employment
issue example in the salary issue example in the
question knows about education and example knows
in the quality of the human being that  we
want to create a fraternal human being, a
human being that symbolizes love and not
war, the boy and not hate, that's what I
was very grateful for And you would like
everyone to be like you,
but the possibility is a possibility, the
human being does not  Rui is born
and he is made bad he is transformed
he learns to be bad being just being
bad we have no obligation to teach you
are good
Hi and we learn to be good at
home following your example and I really appreciate
this time you spent with us
forced to